[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
think back you may remember joe biden's
infrastructure bill this fall that bill
emerged from congress in november with a
price tag of 1.2 trillion dollars
at so many zeros it's hard to imagine
how much is it well it's more than the
entire gdp of the nation of mexico one
of the world's biggest oil producers by
the way so that's a ton of money
so for a bill that size you'd expect
well big results you'd certainly want
better roads than they've got in mexico
so are we getting those what are we
getting exactly from that bill
well today the transportation department
which is now run by mayor pete but a
judge of south bend finally told us the
answer
effective immediately we learned this
country will undergo a quote paradigm
shift in the way we think about
infrastructure
now hold on a minute as you probably
noticed by this point the moment
paradigm starts shifting you can be
certain a whole lot of people are about
to get shafted
nothing personal it's just the nature of
paradigms they don't just shift they
tend to topple over and crush innocent
bystanders
and this paradigm of course is no
different
according to the new paradigm we learned
about today infrastructure is no longer
about roads and bridges and airports and
train stations and things you might
actually use in the course of your life
we could fix those things but why bother
mayor pete has better ideas
here's mr douglas emhoff the profoundly
unemployed husband of kamala harris to
explain
so when we talk about transportation
we're not just talking about buildings
and roads and bridges all the important
stuff as well but we're talking about
the safety of our children the safety of
our families
and this as you know is something that
president biden vice president harris
secretary buda judge
this entire department of transportation
this administration
deeply understands they deeply
understand
and when they kind of grin and go like
that you know you're about to get
screwed
we're not just talking about things you
care about anymore mr mrs america those
stupid buildings and roads and bridges
things that you can touch
and we're talking about bigger things
now we're talking about vast structural
problems
problems so big that unemployed doug
emhoff can't even really describe them
much less solve them things like quote
the safety of our children and our
families
turns out big problems are a lot safer
to talk about in speeches because you
can't actually do anything about them so
there are no expectations
roads and bridges and buildings are very
different from that they need concrete
and asphalt and rebar stuff that's
expensive and hard to do
and that may be why our buildings roads
and bridges are falling apart
according to the american society of
civil engineers which keeps track of
these things there are more than 617
000 bridges in this country and as of
tonight more than 46 000 of those
bridges are considered quote
structurally deficient
that means they're in terrible shape
kind of a big deal for a bridge
as for our roads fully 43 of all public
roadways in this country are quote in
poor or mediocre condition in other
words we actually are mexico though a
lot richer
so what are we going to do about this
what is the 1.2 trillion dollar plan
going to do for our crumbling
infrastructure well people just has a
plan here it is
more speed cameras
according to the associated press but a
judge would like to quote promote
greater use of speed cameras which the
department says could provide more
equitable enforcement than police
traffic stops
got that so because of equity you're
about to get a lot more speeding tickets
from robots
see how that works shut up races pay the
fine
the government does need the money for
infrastructure even after 1.2 trillion a
recent new york times piece put it this
way quote when california voters
approved a bond in 2008 for a high speed
rail system from la to san francisco the
project was supposed to cost 33 billion
and be completed by 2020. that job is
now projected to finish in 2033 for a
hundred billion though those estimates
are dated and there is an 80 billion
dollar funding gap
so infrastructure is expensive actually
no one really knows how much
infrastructure costs because
infrastructure never gets completed
there are still working trains in the
state of california unfortunately
they're now getting robbed just like
they were in the 1870s return to the
future
union pacific is now contemplating
abandoning the state after more than 150
years there kind of a big deal what does
mayor pete think of this he's the
transportation secretary
hasn't said a single word about it of
course there's nothing to do with equity
so it's beneath his radar
by the way it's not just trains that are
in trouble in this country we're also
short 80 000 truck drivers and that
could be part of the reason that these
shelves at your local grocery store are
getting bare and it's not just trucks
either
by next year airlines are expected to be
short more than 10 000 pilots
and that's why between christmas eve and
new year's eve airlines canceled more
than 10 000 flights that was this year
good luck getting to florida next year
now there are other causes of the
cancellations none of which mayor pete
is doing anything to fix he's for vax
mandates of course that was a huge cause
of the shortage this year and then there
are others so the president of emirates
probably the best airline in the world a
man called tim clark recently slammed
mayor pete and the administration for
the disastrous rollout of 5g technology
near airports that led to a total
suspension of emirates flights clark
said it was quote one of the most
delinquent utterly irresponsible
decisions he's ever seen in his long
career
fox's casey stegall has covered the
collapse of the transportation network
in this nation here's an overview
more chaos for folks trying to get home
after the holidays i've been here since
last night yeah so they canceled and now
i'm getting a flight with united
hopefully leaving this afternoon
airlines canceling thousands of flights
on tuesday and delaying thousands more
leaving anxious passengers stranded and
frustrated at airports around the
country the widespread groundings and
delays due to a combination of winter
weather and coven 19 staffing
disruptions on flights and also around
airports the winter weather not only
affecting air travel drivers also facing
traffic snags due to snow and icy roads
hundreds stranded overnight on a 50-mile
stretch of i-95 near fredericksburg
virginia
well things were bad in virginia but
it's not just virginia officials in
connecticut recently reported
285 car crashes because of quote icy
weather oh
forgot to salt the roads
same in new york state westchester
county people killed oh forgot to salt
the roads the feds didn't salt the roads
people died
what does that do with equity
so here you have roads you can't drive
on airports that don't work planes that
don't take off and trains that are
getting robbed
these are not small things when your
transportation network falls apart in a
continental country
things grind to a halt everything
depends upon moving objects and people
from one place to another because it's a
huge country
so if you have problems like these which
are central to our economy and the way
we live to the country itself it might
be a good idea to hire a competent
transportation secretary but that's not
what the buy administration did
they had a more progressive idea
joe biden hired a kid by contrast who
had
never had a real job outside mckinsey
and no grounding of any kind in physical
reality
we know this because he was the mayor of
south bend
so what's the infrastructure life like
in south bend
well when pete but a judge was mayor the
city had him we're quoting now the worst
pothole situation in the state according
to the local paper huge potholes so big
that mayor pete not a tall man could
have disappeared into one good pictures
little legs up in the air
eight years as mayor and he was never
able to fix it
with just enough resources to replenish
the paving of every lane mile of street
in our city only every 100 years or so i
faced a constant battle with that
natural enemy of all mayors the pothole
so it's a guy
who literally couldn't fix the potholes
in south bend indiana
is now the transportation secretary
buddy breastfeed so it's equity
[Laughter]
it's unbelievable
pretty amusing
this is a guy who wouldn't know a car
transmission from a bridge abutment what
are the chances he can run his own
espresso machine
the mindset is the problem here and it's
not just mayor pete he's easy to mock
because he's a ludicrous figure
but it's all the people like him who
believe that our economy is based on
social media apps and hr departments
people like that really believe that by
social engineering you can make the
trains run on time and you can create a
robust economy because they're morons
for example last week
mayor pete explained that the number one
priority of the transportation
department in the middle of a massive
shortage of transportation workers
trains are getting robbed planes that
won't take off
is equity
so you know we need to do we need to
work extra hard to screen out anybody
who might be working in our
transportation industry who happens to
have the wrong skin color watch
you look at something like the
investment in transit you know it's it's
americans of color commuters of color
who are most likely to depend on that
you look at the jobs we're going to
create and yeah they have been
traditionally white and male but it
doesn't have to stay that way we are
working with a lot of focus at the
direction of the president to make sure
that everything from the contracting
opportunities for small business to the
labor opportunities for workers fixing
the bridges installing the electric
vehicle charging stations are more
likely to be workers of color are more
likely to be women
so that's kind of the problem and that's
been the problem with our trains and
planes and automobiles for a century now
too many white people in them
got a lot of white airline pilots that's
the problem mayor pete just said that
doesn't have to be this way
that's equity
so this is where your 1.2 trillion
dollars is going
to what is i mean not to get technical
in a legal campaign to hire workers on
the basis of their skin color
so mayor pete you may have noticed is
the wrong skin color and as long as you
want to diversify and equify
transportation why is he running the
department
because he's too important to give up
his job to an unqualified haitian
migrant
that's because mayor pete can see the
big picture he understands that every
transportation decision is in fact
something so much bigger
let me take
50 seconds to walk through our top
priorities
and then let's just jump into the
conversation so our focus is on safety
of course that's why our department
exists
it is on economic development and the
ways of good infrastructure create jobs
it is on equity in the knowledge that we
can either do harm or do enormous good
in terms of who gets the opportunities
we create and where they go
it is about climate recognizing that
every transportation decision is a
climate decision whether we acknowledge
that or not
we couldn't understand everything he
said because for some reason he had a
freaking mask on his face
maybe he was robbing a train not clear
we've got a reporter getting to the
bottom of that but we think we heard him
say
that his job is to work on climate
it's funny
when the country applauded 1.2 trillion
going to fixing the roads bridges and
buildings a lot of us were dumb enough
to think that's what might actually
happen
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else